yeah so i've never done i love stand up
you started stand up late in your career
yeah i always want to do it i do love it
because i get to write perform my own
material like i got to do on saturday
night live so i i do love it yeah and
and it's like having the lead in a movie
as opposed to you know i do a lot of
these cameos and movies and i don't do
them anymore i don't enjoy it it's like
one day too it's like i'm trying to do
the whole show so
so uh you don't like doing movies i do
but it's enough with the cameo it's like
it's not fun because you gotta like it's
it's not it's not a challenge it's just
it's just you know
you if you got a call today to go spend
the day on a movie set you'd say no
yeah
okay well then i feel twice as honored
that you didn't say no to us that you're
here this is not a movie it's just a
podcast no but it's i guess it's about
me
no but a cameo
okay it's like it's like uh
you know
you're you're you're an athlete and you
run the mile they go can you run 10 feet
you're like well yeah i run a mile
though that's what i do
they go well just run 10 feet we'll pay
you all right so then you do but it's
boring it's boring for me it i i feel
incredibly lucky and grateful that that
i'm still able to work at all that's
wonderful so i don't take any job for
granted but it's just not fun it's just
i'd rather do stand-up i get to do a
whole show is that better than wiping
asses or giving uh enemas into the wrong
hole
well i would say
the critic was the most fun of voiceover
then wiping a butt and then stand up wow
in that order wow yes it's better than
wiping a butt do you think you'll ever
get married it's even better than wiping
my own butt
do you sometimes wipe the wrong hole
please do not tell us that story
[Music]
well now i have to tell it because you
said don't just sing a song one time
go ahead
[Laughter]
i'm in the bathroom by myself listening
to me by yourself are you by yourself
yeah i'm finished it's time to cleanse
and i'm cleansing and suddenly
i hear
wrong hole
[Laughter]
i don't know who said it
and i go well i'm alone it wasn't me but
i heard it wrong hole wow
and i looked and it was indeed the wrong
hole
wow
these are and like you i thought
[ __ ] holes do i have down there right
i don't know but it was the wrong one i
love that and i love that you shared it
with that's true story
[Music]
you